I feel like it'd be natural for you guys
to also have Adam as one of your first
guests
wow I didn't think about that why not
bro clear up all the [__] you know
because I feel like you guys genuinely
probably I mean you guys like you just
said you have love for Adam yeah I'm
sure the feeling's mutual I do [__] that
we giving the beef going
like like I do think like like t-ro like
you were saying I think it's like a big
learning curve with all this [__] yeah
because like I feel like no jumper had
like evolved into something it had never
been before so I'm sure like you know
there's a learning curve on how to deal
with all these personality I mean the
[__] got fired on camera bro you
know what I'm saying like that
how do you feel like that you know what
I'm saying as a business owner right now
here doing content like would you would
have you know ever did any of that
there's so much stuff that has happened
over there me and Eric my producer we
talk about it all the time yeah like it
ain't worth it it's just not it's not
would you like you know would you ever
as a boss go and fire Eric like look
Eric this camera you the camera rolling
Eric your ass fire get your well I mean
I kind of fired him before but not like
that I was like hey man you want to be a
famous photographer I need somebody who
wants to be a famous podcast producer
are you throwing shots on my boys
[Applause]
he's a huge photographer he did the fact
he did the last Fat Joe album cover oh
that's right that's not why bro no no
and him are big photographers see this
is how we do it I see what you're doing
I live in [__] Burbank I won't be
able to go anywhere what are you trying
to do to me man [__] oh my God I'm
honorary Armenian I don't know if you
know me too yeah of course I've been to
three Armenia weddings and a Mexican
oh my wife's Mexican okay aren't you no
I'm not mad we've already gone through
this you know this your wife is Hispanic
I have two Mexican children damn she be
whooping your ass in there huh
in there
man
[Laughter]
it's funny because that [__] is real
because they came here like two weeks
ago well that's just real real and
she carved her [__] their initials
into the table right there oh that's
crazy the whole she was like this like
pissed and like I'm like what do you
but like an hour prior to them getting
here like well they were here an hour
prior to the interview starting they
were just yelling at each other while he
was getting his hair cut in the other
building I'm sorry Kev that's probably
someone that's probably the best vagina
on this planet to continue to deal with
that I don't even bro I'm gonna be
honest let me give you some head [__]
people like oh my God I forget
everything I'm gonna be I think I think
that wipe it away I think being being
near them for a couple of hours it made
me kind of realize like well now that
she's sober
live on the blue face side I feel like
he's kind of running up the numbers
right now because he kind of knows like
let's go viral no no I said it in the
interview I'm like yo she's more popping
than you he's like yeah she signed to me
I want her to be more popular
whoa oh so he's running it up I think
that's more of what's happening so it's
not real no it is real but I mean she's
pregnant God I mean it's a sad situation
I think that whole thing like it's like
kind of what is it worth it the numbers
the money but yeah some of the no jumper
[__] that happened like I definitely
would not name something
talk about it
um I mean the firing thing you know I
think
um
I just think that like I was telling
Adam the same [__] like lie to me Lush
no sometimes
um just some of the like I feel like uh
we would talk about like it felt like
sometimes he would just be having random
gang members on that don't really ain't
doing [__] but are gang members I don't
know yeah there was like a little like
point in time it was an error there was
like an era like the [__] Mack era where
it felt like every other guy on the show
was fascinated with street closer and it
was like uh so and so on being a
something something [__] and going to
jail and being white yeah
like no substance there
I mean but what the [__] are you
supposed to do when no artists gonna
come through there you know what I'm
saying it works right like yes like like
to me like I can't even well like to me
the the no jumper thing has worked it is
way bigger than what I'm doing but you
know for for me like just a lot of the
like uh the [__] that happened with
house phone you know I think was was uh
terrible it was mishandled flagrantly
even even if it wasn't meant to be Miss
handle flake really like
like I was telling him I was like bro
that that wouldn't even that wasn't even
a sniff the YouTube that wouldn't even
got
you can't even load that up and that's
and that's where accountability goes
into play right well I was just saying
and then even here in the do-no thing
you know like what he said about like
asking for something to get taken down
I've taken stuff down
because I'm like cool with an artist and
they're like hey man I'm getting some
[__] can you take that [__] down and
I'm like yeah sure bro like if I if
anything I'm doing like is gonna affect
your day negatively and it ain't even
going crazy like that on YouTube I'll
[__] and this was like life and death
situation except little pup I kept his
[__] up [__] him anyway
oh my God he gave out my [__] phone
number on on the internet
what did you do bro I asked him if if he
thought J Cole predicted his career
correctly
and then it came out and then him and
his team are blowing me the [__] up are
we trying to stop from coming out I'm
like bro
well first of all the interview you you
actually like came off like not like a
little [__] in the interview and
like yeah no it's coming out bro like it
is what it is so then they didn't like
the way I titled the interview so then I
changed the title
so I changed the title to like something
nicer right and it wasn't even titled
badly
and then
his manager calls me and is like
he said I better take it down I said I
better take it down or what you know
where I'm at the [__]
I'll be there all day tomorrow what do
you mean you're [__] Square from
Miami some little white dude calls me
and then I got off the phone with him
and then so you got people white people
I told you he posted my phone number why
all y'all got beef with each other like
that why you got no beef with no white
people little pump see no pump's not
white is he he's like a Puerto Rican
Colombian something and I actually like
talk a little pump you know he's Cuban I
didn't know that no that's all about the
manager pull up whitey
oh my God Whitey
what yeah but yeah then my phone was
going crazy for like [__] a month
straight
I put it on airplane mode then like
right when it happened but do my
WhatsApp like people when I [__]
pasty fat white [__] sending me net
nudes and [__] thinking it was a little
pump
it was it was wild bro it was like ain't
that bad